thank you
[Music]
and we've got some shirtless men in the
room we're just giving uh babes
beefcakes for the editor right there
just get them in there we're gonna get
views up guys we gotta get [ __ ]
videos show some nips on the Channel Hey
Joe looking pretty good there oh bars
looking something else looking better uh
Joe or Bart bye Joe let's objectify
these men a little realistically today
definitely Joe bar on the milking his
own titties thing was catching me like
he's still got red marks above his nip
I have a lot of rib eye left man is that
what that was
I think I know you too well I think
you've been cheating with some different
kinds of food that sounds like some
cupcakes now I've actually been really
strict for the last three and a half
weeks so far here he's running down 10
pounds he's real cheap meals how long
how long has it been since uh your
weight loss Journey with Geo they're
doing a competition yeah who's winning
three and a half weeks I actually uh we
waiting yesterday I'm winning so far of
course you're a guy you're obliterating
her dude she probably lost like you also
have a lot more weight to lose yeah no
but that's why we're doing at the end of
it we're doing a dexa scan to it's so
we're basing off of body fat percentage
rather than total weight loss because it
should be like a ratio right now yeah I
think you win dude yes I think you win
you hear that yeah Gino
a kangaroo oh kangaroo I love kangaroos
man yeah they're also known as Joey's
western part of the world kangaroo ran
loose in Baton Rouge Louisiana
yeah I know right he escaped the zoo uh
backyard suit is it a private Zoo ran
loose in Baton Rouge area after a parrot
set it free damn how did a parrot do
that I think who unlocked the gate I
think talking animal movies have some
real [ __ ] have some real [ __ ] going on
Doctor Doolittle based off a true story
it's like a babe situation right here so
Baxter the kangaroo is safe after he
spent a day running loose in East Baton
Rouge but law enforcement says that
marsupial will need to find a new home
after the Escape
why because
the owner died of a heart attack
negative because apparent it's got It's
got kangaroo AIDS no exotic exotic
animals pets you can't have any that are
non-native to United States any animal
not native to the United States anything
venomous you cannot have an East Baton
Rouge Parish so it says the director of
Animal Control and rescue center so they
shot us illegally there then yeah so
this dude who's illegally uh the pet
owner if you will of a kangaroo in Baton
Rouge and he's got a Parrot as well and
this parrot literally uh [ __ ] unlocks
the holding cell that this kangaroo is
in and so Baxter the kangaroo gets free
and starts hopping around and stuff like
that just picked up and found by police
or is notified by like neighbors that
are like that's a [ __ ] kangaroo out
here please find them Animal Control
gets called and stuff like that so he's
safe and sound he's found he's returned
only you can't have a [ __ ] kangaroo
as a pet so in Texas
Nevada Maybe
do you think do you think one of the
neighbors was like explaining to his
wife because if this was me Nikki's like
that's a kangaroo and I'm like babe
that's not a kangaroo kangaroos are not
in America
you live from Australia that can't be a
king listen [ __ ] stop spewing stupidity
out of your mouth you don't understand
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
actually don't understand what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's kangaroo and like that's
a kangaroo and then immediately you guys
like how do I backtrack this oh god oh I
really went hard on that one
us like you're worried about your
reputation
dude you know how guys are bro I'm like
I'm like we parked the car right here I
[ __ ] know it you [ __ ] D4 with the
Donald Duck on it I saw it right back
and then we're standing there she's like
where's the car see where's the car
green where's the car and I'm like I
have never gonna live this down
why did I go so hard and then he's just
like wait we walked here
we didn't even take the car
so uh there are no exceptions to the
ordinance obviously you cannot have a
kangaroo but the owners have one week to
find Baxter new home or they face fines
this was what my future career would
have been if I continued selling
piranhas oh I think it would be like
piranhas to like illegal Turtles Gateway
she would you would also just be Joey
exotic and maybe maybe alligators
whatever imagine Joe Exotic but with
even more jerking off
and more murder more gay sex dude
yo that wedding scene was one of the
best I've ever ever where he kissed both
dudes and then like that's pretty
[ __ ] baller dude that guy's like the
damn Bilzerian of like exotic pet like I
don't even know who Dan Bilzerian is you
remember I don't know danville's area
he's like the poker player with all the
girls he would love his Instagram page
that's your dream I've never actually
seen him because he was covered in women
yeah just like Anthony
tiny little legs that's right see some
of his beard and that's it he's the
Armenian uh Johnny Bravo dunk on him for
his skinny legs do you think he got
skinny legs he's got I never looked at
his legs I don't know he's definitely
got small calves yeah like when you see
him in proportion everything else you're
like that's kind of weird looking but
you're also kind of weird looking so so
other than Joe and his piranha
Adventures if you guys could have an
exotic animal as a monkey spider monkey
spider monkey spider
hilarious he's [ __ ] scared what about
chimpanzee hell yeah I love a champagne
I want a chimpanzee rip your [ __ ]
face off bro but you gotta be nice to
him dude you gotta get them you gotta
get the monkey from Ace Ventura when
it's like a child only Curious George
age nah so it's a spider monkey then
spider monkey Ace Ventura spider monkey
spider monkey listen babe that's a
spider monkey I [ __ ] know it you know
what I kind of don't think it's a spider
monkey dude it's absolutely what a
spider monkey looks like they called you
babe yeah me too is that the one with
the white circle around the head it's
like everything else is black
what kind of monkey likes to take hot
baths in Japan oh no it's that it's that
it's not a Japanese senior citizen you
just want an old Japanese person I just
want someone to take hot baths have you
seen a Japanese monkey taking like a hot
bath no they look like Japanese grandpas
if you guys want to spend the rest of
the day watching monkey videos I'm down
let's do it that's my favorite one
Japanese monkey taking a bath dude it's
the [ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] like it it
looks like my future like we're gonna be
looking like that if we're if we're
inside of a [ __ ] jacuzzi they're
gonna be like oh look at those two
chimpanzees they pick at each other's
hairs too and take the little bugs out
judge it's a cop oh he's a white-headed
Capuchin that guy see I need someone to
go in the sauna with me does that look
like a Japanese grandpa hard on
something and being wrong
I'm Nikki dude look at that [ __ ]
Japanese grandpas they're so great
they're awesome is that full playing
with his fart bubbles no he's just like
it's like helping them groom and stuff
oh I think he's just playing with the
water how hot is that water it's
probably like warm I don't know
it's snowing outside yeah they're just
having a good time they're probably
trying to survive it's it's ice cold
he's probably coming up with a [ __ ]
Haiku right now
banana banana water that's just gonna be
terrible I wanted to see them but I
didn't get the chance to where do you
see them at the hot springs in the wild
in Japan so there's chilling there yeah
they're there do they attack humans they
just [ __ ] bathe all day you uh
there's like there's like I mean it's
not a what do you call it like a park
like you could pay an entry fee but
they're just running like a wildlife
preserve or something kind of yeah but
it's like owned by someone do that a
monkey try to [ __ ] steal my glasses
in Bali yeah did you punch that monkey
in the face punch them in the [ __ ]
heads I didn't need them
have you seen those videos of like
people going to like Bali and [ __ ] and
the monkey who steal their purse and all
that stuff and they're trained they
bring it back to the owner yup they take
it up the tree and then it's gone and
then Olive Garden's like it's gone [ __ ]
and then later on yeah they go resell it
[ __ ] I like the monkey there's that one
chick she's doing an interview and he
comes up and looks under her skirt yeah
that's a cool monkey along with the
monkey's touching on her titties and
she's just laughing and stuff yeah I
love those videos anytime animals get
away with molestation good vids it's
really good like the giraffe the draft
picks up this chick's tit or something
like that which one is that that's it
the [ __ ] are you watching this there's a
documentary on PornHub yeah yeah yeah
when I was in Japan with my friends the
we're at the inara with the Deer Park
and everything like that and then my
friends are trying to like feed the deer
and then they got like a little too
aggressive so they like each like they
like try to hide the the like crackers
like in their shirt or whatever in this
one girl like hit it in her shirt and
the dude just bitter boob oh [ __ ] she
was like oh [ __ ] that's scary as [ __ ]
those deer those deer are [ __ ]
aggressive and they know they know what
you're losing a nipple how'd you lose
your nipple
gangster story and they're not afraid of
you because no one [ __ ] them up yeah
that's why you gotta [ __ ] them up some
more deer in the face I actually did
punch a [ __ ] emu in the head one time
really what happened he was trying he's
trying was he talking [ __ ] they look he
was he was actually looking at my mother
and then she thought yeah yeah I was
like you get your [ __ ] eyes off my
mind that's my mom
uh no I was wearing a shiny watch and
then they'd he'd bit me it was like
reflexively like I just oh yeah that's
fair you punched him like this like
Irish boxer I punch him like a [ __ ]
man actually there it is
like Will Smith at the at the [ __ ]
Oscars I thought you said Independence
Day when he punched the alien in the
face
that reminds me how to do that punched
the kangaroo who was choke holding his
dog yeah dude
I love how stunned that kangaroo was
after yeah that was a good punch I like
almost like no that's what I call a
close encounter that's like how [ __ ]
that is good that was good that movie's
fire dude I love that movie the second
one sucked ass second one was horrible
it's like ass such a waste of the Third
Kind Will Smith wasn't even in it right
no Wilson wasn't in it goldblums was
back yeah whatever always comes back
yeah I kind of I love Jackal I love him
right he just looks like he's having so
much fun no matter what he's doing he
just looks like he's gonna come back to
every [ __ ] [ __ ] franchise has ever
participated in as a reboot let's see a
fly another fly I would see another fly
not if they're gonna arm wrestle again
that seems hokey looking
that [ __ ] gave me nightmares when I was
getting for sure yeah all that body came
out today yeah oh today love it
because he was in Thor Ragnarok so I was
just thinking about that the new new huh
the new
Newport that's good though I I think the
ratings are okay really not as good as
Thor Ragnarok Ragnarok was too good
taika can do no wrong tiger ytc can do
some wrong probably bro I'm so comic
book movied out it's like insane yeah
I'm over it too they'll give you another
one I know they will and then another
one green Punisher
you didn't watch it no I think you would
[ __ ] love you don't like seeing
people get killed you look like the
Japanese John Bernthal punished your
character in real life be a Punisher
maybe I'll give it a chance watch it
it's I like seeing the memes or he's
like strapped to the chair he's like no
no no yeah yeah yeah
I judge shows on the quality of the
memes now you should I do really yeah
[Music]
laughs
foreign